raphaël vaugirard bonjour bonjour
monsieur car oui j'ai bonjour à la
martinique et surtout au goût monnaie
vous avez justement déjà été candidat à
l'élection municipale au gros morne en
et vous avez décidé de retenter votre
chance l'an prochain pourquoi raphaël
vaugirard et qu'est ce qui serait
susceptible
cette fois-là de vous faire gagner alors
monsieur quand wish je ne veux pas
contre quelqu'un je ne venais pas dans
un affrontement de personnes mais je
vais pour ma commune pour défendre le
savez j'ai été conseiller général et je
connais parfaitement la situation
sociale économique environnementale et
toutes les questions qui se posent aux
gones y compris la question du
chlordécone puisque le moment c'est une
grosse commune bananière non je suis
candidat mais pas un candidat
autoproclamé
je suis candidat et il choisit juste un
candidat issu d'un de tout un mouvement
de rassemblement qui a été initiée par
je dois le dire monsieur max morinière
qui a réuni toutes les anciennes têtes
de liste de 2014 pour qu'on puisse
éviter le remake de 2014 donc voilà pour
elle c'est andy dans je suis pas un
autoproclamé je vais parce que j'ai été
choisi et quel que je pense être en
mesure de rassembler et ils n'ont pas le
diviser et surtout d'apporter de
l'apaisement dans notre commune parce
que il faut qu'on ait vu tout ce qui est
violence tout ce qui est règlement de
comptes
ça n'a pas sa place dans une élection
mais le bilan de la mandature qui va
s'achever sous la houlette de gilbert
couturier est ce que vous pensez que ce
bilan
justement est en mesure de changer la
donne et de pouvoir vous faire gagner
alors des choses des choses
six ans et demi ce couturier j'ai bien
dit que je ne fais pas de règlements de
compte le maire sortant mais on peut dit
ok on peut tromper tout le monde une
fois mais on va pas tromper tout le
monde tout le temps et la population du
gourmand estiment avoir été trompés en
2014 pourquoi le bilan est
catastrophique
tous les lieux qui organisent la vie
quotidienne au goût monde sont formés
sont fermés
qu'ils cessent de l'église pour les
personnes âgées le stent pour nous
associer à son pour le jeune la
bibliothèque symbole de l'accès à la
culture et fermez la
tine est fermé le manche et le cap nord
à financer n'a pas été inaugurée donc
c'est vraiment une destruction de tous
qui organisent la vie augmente en
conséquence il ya un grand mouvement de
mécontentement
un grand mouvement de déception et je
pense que la population je vous ai bien
des clients qui pensait avoir été
trompés ne va pas tant de se tromper
cette fois alors vous avez fait allusion
à un certain nombre de difficultés
selon vous que que connaît la la commune
par rapport à 2,3 sujet précis mais si
vous êtes élu l'an prochain raphaël
vaugirard au gros-morne quel sera votre
chantier prioritaire à vous et votre
équipe à la municipalité à l'eau côté
j'ai plusieurs chantiers de fond et tout
de suite
le premier chantier c'est de rétablir la
confiance entre les élus et les
administrés pour que les élus parlent un
langage de vérité à la population et non
pas en fumée avec des promesses qui ne
sont pas tenir la population donc ça
vaut mais chantier mais un deuxième
immédiat c'est celui de refaire le p lus
de la commune qui a grugé des centaines
de familles dans leur patrimoine
un pe injuste qui a été adoptée le 4
décembre 2010 un plan local d'urbanisme
plan local d'urbanisation et moi oui
et puis et puis je veux aussi mettre
notre commune en mode projet nous avons
une quantité de chantier à sortir qu'ils
cessent de l'église très attendue de la
population de stents le marché et puis
des zones d'activités pour nos
entreprises
et puis soignées les questions
d'environnement et puis je pense aussi à
la question du chlordécone leur gaumont
nous avons beaucoup de décès conscient
il conduit dans ma famille donc nous
pensons qu'une initiative pour
accompagner les gens les accueillit les
efforts mais parce que les gens ne
savent pas toujours comment faire pour
le signer se sent pas bien lorsqu'il on
le soupçonne le cancer
comment faire donc il ya ce qu'on
appelle le plan informations le point
information conscients que nous nous
pensons proposer à la populace
alors quel est l'enjeu
qu'est-ce qui va se jouer pour la cette
fois-ci non pas l'équipe municipale qui
va arriver aux affaires
ou qui sera renouvelée mais où qui aura
regagné la confiance donc des électrices
et des électeurs du gros morne mais là
du point de vue de la ville et de ses
habitants quel est l'enjeu essentiel
finalement du prochain scrutin selon
vous raphaël un joueur essentiel c'est
de relever logo monde se prend un autre
slogan c'est ruiz les gones un cce ont
ordonné aux gones et la fierté de la
commune et puis nous voulons aussi
mettre comme je vous ai dit un mot de
projets parce que le logo c'est une
commune rurale
nous avons des atouts énormes en matière
d'agriculture en matière touristique en
matière culturelle
nous avons subi qu'un lit avec nous
avons maxxo il ya des champions sir ken
d'enchantement leur domaine nous voulons
faire de ses leaders et des gens qui
vont proposer un autre avenir notre
commune afin de vaugirard
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions le
rappelle vous un candidat donc à
l'élection municipale
alors c est le nom de notre mouvement
c'est sos de santé c'est pourquoi nous
poussons un sos pour sauver le gaumont
merci